en jet je vais te montrer des
personnalités on va faire le dard
qu'aura sera d'accord jeff et jean-marc
je vous montre des personnalités tu me
dis si elle est pour toi elles sont
barca ou si elles sont rares sera
d'accord c'est parti dard qu'aura sera
on y va
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en profite pour embrasser maître gims
qui est venu exprès pour faire le
guignol
il vient de partir de la régie là il est
venu il avait un de rendre deux rendez
vous c'est la partie
merci c'est bon c'est dans la boîte
allez attention je te demande des photos
tu me dis d'art qu'aura sera la première
photo lalanne normalement alors les
photos ça mais eux deux heures parce
qu'il tape en fait le vrai blast des
mecs sur google merci michel pautot
marca
dar k et toi t'as qu'à ces tutus le oui
oui c'est fait partie des gens qui nous
ont tendu la main quand on n'était pas
très connu et ouais il a invité sur sur
leur plateau et voilà c'est vrai cette
analyse michel merci michel ont dit
toute façon je vous dire on téléfoot
toujours dire oui même si vous l'avez
jamais vu de votre ca de michel drucker
non mais c'est la règle d'or et anona
aussi quoi faut dire aussi merci hanouna
aujourd'hui ouais ouais
par quoi donc on peut dire aussi au
revoir bucchini des bauges élimination
qu'est ce que ça lui être luc sata plus
la marque à bas mais c'est sympa parce
que c'était de la grosse merde c'est un
jour jean marc est malade tu ne pourras
la place
[Rires]
or à paris ça va partir
on sait pas où ça va arriver non mais
non disait merci jeff cet opus est un
projet qui peut te plaire non mais faut
qu'on en discute et se monnaye attention
dar kaoua sera deuxième photo mais les
faut on est copain patrick sébastien
c'est ce que je batte d'arcachon obligé
je sais c'est lui qui avec qui tu as
fait faire ta patrie qui m'a découvert
dans un sac voilà dans un petit cabaret
il est venu me voir il m'a dit viens
dans mon émission et voilà depuis il se
bat depuis je passe tout ce qui se passe
donc voilà je peux pas dire passera et
je suis allé tourner sa dernière
émission et c'était vraiment vraiment
très très touchant de la retrouver à ce
moment voilà selon moi c'est très fort
derrière patrick tient prochains mois
tous y aller la taille et la série a
sera barka ba oui
ouais je suis désolé des faux culs mais
vous vous mettez tous les gens que les
dames ou alors les gens qui sont venus
dans mon émission a très gentiment
méthodiste jamais été le 10 mai tel 10
gt le dise ah bah non car ils ont mis
des tice yal'idée ce pas celle que je
voulais des tilleuls idéaux par les
urnes ne connaît pas on n'est pas peu
dire d'abbas est pour l'instant assez g
après impression lara sera pour elle
mais j'espère que ça va s'arranger en
tout cas moi je moi je m'occupe à tout
ça par ailleurs on essaie juste de
garder les bons moments voilà tu as bien
raison le 10 ou le lot 1 thierry
ardisson cadart qu'aura ce radar car
désolé le terrain danois sedar com
tu seras ou quoi il aime tout le monde
par quoi pouvoir rien mais il faut
mettre des gens alors vous vous diriez
quoi d'arcore à sera lui oui maratrat
mêlée sur notre chaîne connaît mais mon
collègue on est comme ça les deux à
marcoule à 600 milles ça marche bien
arrête de dire des conneries ça va j'ai
réduit il est quand même terrible insu
un crevard fait un petit peu dire swan a
fait un petit peu noir ça lui en fait il
n'a pas compris il n'a pas compris le
principe du ventriloque faut pas bouger
la bouche
ah ben oui mais ça c'est un autre
exercice pas mal et il fait déjà
franchement qu'il imite suis le seul
mais comme on a imité une marionnette
chum premier il m'en voudrais toute sa
vie devant eux s'en souviendra de sa
d'accord voilà alors allez allez dire
faites le mais son chroniqueur pour
l'actionnaire